SUIM everybody became Catholic for the
day everything that and they get
everybody who's live-streaming watching
us right now from the cover of your
living room we have a night full of
awesome science ahead and are you
feeling the love are you feeling the
love Mitchell the cockloving here I feel
the love but there's something I
actually really dislike about love
what's that Mitchell what's that not
about the act itself but it's the fact
that the heart gets all the credit but
the brain actually does all the work
that's some truth that's some truth t
image oh we actually decided to write a
song about it to show our frustration
ladies and gentlemen this is the science
of love song I'll be the spark if you'll
be the flame start a reaction that can't
be contained balance your pH by sharing
my base I'll be your star if you'll be
my space coz there's no distance that I
can go to space-time and wormholes my
matter would flow to the edge of the
universe I'll be your G if you will be C
or I can be a if you will be T if
there's a mutation I'll fix every base
working as your zinc finger nucleases
like an atom don't rip us apart unless
you wanna make room in my heart
we can take it fast or really slow but
we can't know with certainty where we'll
go at first we don't succeed we'll try
two more times so our failures are
statistically significant try
like an equation it oversize
exercise
into
this is your science left song
a place to start our chemical bomb
a research endeavor
gonna write the conclusion together just
like a movie I'd seal your heart but
then you die so I won't do that if we
broke up I know I give up bitch - oh for
h2so4 you could take away gravity and
I'd still fall for you share my last
electron in a covalent bad far down cuz
you like that angle a cute and you're
smart
laughs groaning goggles go straight to
my heart
the heart doesn't feel this is what we
were talking about hashtag truth comes
alive the brain seals the dam
this is your size
her research and
the
today to the bibliography of course a
layer
to
okay thank you guys thank you so we this
is when we were gonna start a Q&A and we
were gonna maybe ask each other
questions and answers but we spend all
of our time together than any question
on how for him I already know the answer
- OH
so we started thinking about like who
would be appropriate to ask us questions
who a love science as much as we do and
B loves us as much as we love us and
only came down to one person really
ladies and gentlemen Jake Roper hi this
is wonderful hello hello hi oh my
goodness I have accept science is good
aesthetically pleasing it is is gorgeous
and Did you touch the hard cover yeah oh
so good I'm pretty sure you can get that
at ASAP science that car can you you
can't it just come out I think that came
insane and obviously everyone here loves
the book already that was enthusiasm but
I'm looking that you guys do answer you
ask interesting questions and answer
them interestingly as well but I have
some questions I would like to ask you
both if we could look hey it's alright
oh please take a seat
thank across my legs very slowly there's
you look directly at all of you as I do
it but ah did you feel something I felt
something actually did you know um when
you're in love the achieving your brain
is similar to when you're on cocaine
yeah I learned that in the a sense plug
right there
natural dress hmm Wow I know okay so are
they even make ones that have the
YouTube symbol on them good job YouTube
woo spending your money wisely um so
first Mitch Craig take why did you
decide to start a sub science and when
did you realize it would need to be a
full-time job Wow
like many people after university we
were a little lost then we didn't really
how we were gonna do I went off to
Teachers College so I learned a lot
about how you know young people were
learning from YouTube whenever I put
YouTube on in the classroom is when the
kids would actually like stop talking
and listen so that got me thinking about
it yeah and I had met some youtubers who
were doing videos and had amazing
content and were like building these
audiences and that's when we first sort
of learned about like what youtubing
West be honest I think about two and a
half years ago when we started the
channel we didn't really have that
concept but we started realizing hey
maybe instead of just forcing our family
and friends to always listen to us we
could force other people to listen to us
instead and it just kind of rolled out
from there yeah and we decided we would
do one video a week for a year and see
what happens as a pet project and now we
have a look and it was the first video
that really kind of like blew up it
makes sense it was the scientific
hangover cure so it's very yeah like
Walter today is yeah for a morning
that's more find out I'm not really
gonna have like what a vibe but we
realized that the video spread like a
virus yeah by wrong here's like
constantly watching refreshing to see
the exact I was actually on the way to
Gregg's house driving I think and had
gotten like hundreds of emails that like
new subscribers I was like oh my god it
broke like um what just happened and
then realize like oh my gosh this videos
been shared so many different places and
I think that was the first instance
where we like understood yeah like what
how far the videos could reach beyond
like my mom and grandma very nice and
then this question actually comes from
somebody maybe here named Danny
it doesn't spirit Danny Thank You Danny
but Danny asks what kind of challenges
if any did you go through to get where
you are now
well one challenge I've got right now is
that working on the Internet it never
stops so we don't really having a tough
time bouncing life and work so it's
something that we love to do and so we
so often are involved hooked onto the
Internet so that's one thing that is
like sort of a challenge trying to
figure out you know when do we stop or
refreshing the page and sort of think
okay like I should look at this tree
because it's prettier so that's one part
yeah I'd say you've been just like
building the channel and starting to
understand like the best way to make
these videos like the biggest challenge
was learning how people learn and I
think we but it was an amazing
experiment for us to like start from
ground zero
and not really be sure where it was
going and then see how some videos did
better than the others and like
understand how the best thumbnail works
or the best title works or whatever and
from there just having that learning
experience the whole way has always been
a challenge but like an exciting
challenge and then you guys are pretty
consistent with doing like a video every
week has that been challenging keeping
up with that yeah a lot of youtubers do
have a day that they come out and so our
first time we're like we're gonna do
them every Wednesday and then that
Wednesday we're like jokes
waiting for today so we scratch that but
that is a really good practice if you
want to be youtuber but we don't follow
it but we do make weekly videos
sometimes I'm gonna have yeah it's like
week ish every week leave it make it
recache video you know quality over
quantity exactly and this is from mario
is there a mario here alright i doing
looking good okay what is the most
amazing experience you have had due to
your youtube excessive success the
pleasure well we kind of had a joke when
we started that like I remember we were
in a backyard with a little you know
notebook as you do being like I'm gonna
do something with my life and he said I
could be so cool if one day we worked
with Bill Nye and then it happened like
kind of early on it was kind of it was a
joke that it was like the goal of the
channel really once we do that we're
done that's all we need to do like maybe
I don't know how far intro but one day
we like got called from your people oh
yeah which was so good to paint
yeah and then we were just like wow
we're life is complete we're done but no
the things went on and we but that was
like surreal for us to think that it
could go from like you know no
subscribers no one having watched the
videos like Bill not being in one but
the book and this is pretty cool like
this is the most sort of it is it you
don't leave our house yes like this is
the first time we've seen so many people
all day long yeah it's awesome like for
the first time yeah is that like it was
great yeah
then this one is from Jill and there
might be multiple Jill's just say this
is two for Jill Jill Jill Jill Jill asks
what was the most shocking thing you
learned while researching the book well
one thing that I personally learned
though that probably wasn't about the
actual research of it was that drawing
for a video which is really kinetic is
much different than drawing for a book
so I was kind like this will be easier
than all sometimes like oh my god this
is so different so that was the most
shocking challenge from yeah going from
like vertical to suddenly horizontal
pages and not being able to use movement
it was just like an interesting
challenge a creative challenge for us
that yeah we were like excited to tackle
but it was definitely hard yeah we did
like the whole design aspect of it was
something was brand new to us and
through us loop but we loved it and it
worked out but it was like it was
challenging but also must be kind of a
different dynamic because generally
you're making a video every week and
with this book it's not like you write
it then it doesn't come out immediately
that's why it's good yeah yeah we won't
find out on that yeah it's exciting
though because there were so many
questions because we only do one vo
because the production of the videos can
take so long yeah we have like like
thousands of questions people have asked
that we've like saved up our favorites
and take from those every now and then
or like most the time rather for the
videos so this was an opportunity to
like answer even more of those uh in the
book for all at once which is really
exciting for us so a lot of the video
ideas come from like fans and viewers
and stuff yeah he's actually yeah
exactly like pretty much every episode
we do have come from some sort of
suggestion whether or not it's like what
got our brain rolling some are
immediately just like oh that's it done
yeah thanks bloodbath but yeah like I
mean we wouldn't be able to do it
because week after week we kind of have
to go back to the drawing board and so
we need to take some inspiration
and the whole point is to find like what
is interesting to other people like we
only represent ourselves and so it's
great just kind of get a sense of what
does the world want to know and how can
we accommodate all these different
styles of learning and interest and
whatnot and so it's essential for us to
sort of hear from everyone out in the
world very nice now we're gonna move to
Twitter which is one of gazas it's like
a Twitter than I have physically write
it on a piece of paper which I thought
was interesting
Oh so alchemy five-four-three asks we
were happy five four three good human
being uh uh who were your biggest
influences in science so Bill Nye was
one which is crazy yeah for sure as a
young age definitely I we always talk
about like we both had great high school
biology teachers and I think that was
kind of like the starting point for us
and probably for many people to be
interested in science and that's why we
talk about now like not everyone is
always as lucky to get like an amazing
teacher in any subject to inspire you
and so that's why online is also so
amazing because you can find so many
different types of people whether it's a
SAP science or whether it's vsauce3 by
the types of channels that you love that
you connect with that can inspire you to
then want to actually go and learn more
so and we also loved York because she
makes the science not really well yeah
but never be like all right all weird
it's like a perfect mix of art and
science
well you don't you have Bjork what was
she like some amazing music video that
you showed we were like oh yeah yeah we
did yeah that's all that zooming in up
to the cell and oh my goodness
yeah it's beautiful you should watch it
yeah I've been water New York and
there's a thing at MoMA yeah MoMA yes
this is fun place now Sam is there a Sam
multiple Sam's how many Sam's were
there's gonna be at least a stand yeah
yeah Sam
for Samantha or Sammy every want to go
which of Sciences weird mysteries would
you like to know the answer to
whew tough questions day yeah yeah oh
yeah Sam
I would love to know what happens every
day that's true that's definitely one of
those questions that's like how do you
test that like Rick I was dying yeah I
think it's an amazing part of life but
it's something that obviously yeah it's
definitely like maybe perhaps one of the
biggest questions but one thing I've
heard about is that people have done
research where they're actually thinking
about how they can actually like use a
specific laser on your skin and like get
enough information to find out like when
biologically you would die which I would
never want to know but I've been the
type of research yeah yeah I know they'd
like for you shake oh my god they're
unhealthy how dare you sir
have you seen this no III think maybe be
worse instead of telling you like a
general years like oh you have ten more
years just say like you're gonna die in
a car accident I'm never getting in a
car ever yeah
but then it's like some of those weird
things where it's like could be getting
in a car being hit by a car and just
knows that yeah you just don't ever
leave I'm fine yeah we just never leave
we were told that that's why we never
like right yeah fair enough and that was
another one from Vanessa yeh does have
an answer hopefully is the same Vanessa
mm what do you think the most important
causes in the world that needs science
hmm that's a good one and if you need
science either you say really sassy like
real science one thing I think is a huge
issue is water and water accessibility I
think that's something where I think
technology and science is going to be
extremely important for ensuring that
people around the world can get it and
Canada doesn't hog it all oh so I think
that's something that's important I
think certainly just the idea of you
know exploration of space and making
sure that we are adequately funding
areas of science that are only going to
further like our understanding of the
world and hopefully lead to better
understanding of how we can conserve
water or technologies of technologies
that will preserve it I think that's
probably like the fundamental aspect is
having people understand the importance
of research and just science in general
is like key to all of the things that
matter yeah well luckily I mean you guys
are kind of doing that right with you to
try and use ooh yeah I think science is
becoming very popular in pop culture and
that is really important yeah I mean it
is an interesting thing a quick little
side note sorry tangents like on tangent
is that science is kind of cool now like
it's it's cool to be curious cuz
everyone is just is inherently curious
we just want to find out the answers to
interesting questions mm-hmm decision to
see that kind of be revitalized in
people
yeah I agree like we do sometimes
wonderful bias because we are so
obsessed with science and talk but all
the time but we do see it a lot do we
realize that you know science has become
really popular for a lot of young people
who watch our videos I mean they're
taking their free time watching it and
falling in love with this science and
curiosity so I do think there is
something there and the dress was an
example for us of laughs
did you see black and blue yeah it's
like what was that real quick well show
of hands was it black or blue white and
gold in your light white and gold we see
white and gold no Oh whew look at you
still brave you're very brave you like
you're in far betray me good yeah that
was an interesting experience to
understand how you can connect with
people like a pop culture thing can be
assigned same I mean we like to call our
channel sometimes like the gateway drug
to science so finding those elements of
like that pop culture element that gets
the whole world interested and then
using science as a way to explain those
things and get interested in more into
science is like important time yeah like
what not happened we were like this is
it Mitch this is our calling like the
Demi Lovato was like explain the science
let's do this drink some coffee and we
did that was an all-nighter like you it
was an all-nighter yeah there was a
moment where we had been like on the
couch we both saw blue bag we're like
this is just a prank like this is so
weird that's not true
and then our roommate came home and she
saw black and blue but then later came
up and she was like oh there's two
pictures this one's letting gold we were
like you've gone to the dark side like
wagon and so then we were like okay this
is crazy
we have something on this so I said you
guys excited I was one of those people
who went into Photoshop and I got the
color picker yeah yeah like everyone no
you're wrong yeah yeah it was just weird
hues all my friends so it's like we have
pressured this question for you their
camera that's on this one from Adam is
there an atom in the room multiple atoms
at all Adam even watching this at home
my heart broke my heart broke Adam do it
did you hear it I did the bed well Adam
asks mm what is one piece of advice
you'd give to aspiring youtubers that
you wish you knew when you started well
one thing that we say a lot and we think
we're like Nike got it right which is
just do it so we feel we feel like
that's the thing and a lot of people do
they ask us for advice it's like you
just have to make YouTube content and
consistently do it and don't give up
when maybe it is just your friends and
family watching and make sure you're
making good content that you're
passionate about and like things will
fall into place so yeah I think the
biggest barrier is like fear of not like
being perfect or having if you go back
and watch our first video
we cringe whenever we look at those
original videos but at the time we were
like really proud of them but if we had
waited to be like perfect we never would
have really started and so it's just do
it just put it out there you learn from
every single video you put out there you
grow you evolve over time and that's
like the best like watch there they're
so bad I would use brown for like
everything everything like the brains
just look like pee and then with the
drawing part
what kind of incentivize that what made
you want to use that format as a way to
get science across well we knew we
wanted the science to come first and we
wanted it to see we know that science
can be really intimidating for people
and so we tried to eliminate that by
being like oh look it's a cartoon but
we're actually gonna explain some
complex pathways so it's kind of like
tricking people that was an original
thought yeah and even sort of strips
like for us it was like how do we make
these videos just about you know this
topic just about the signs of love or
just about how much sleep you needed so
in that sense by sort of taking
ourselves out of the videos we thought
you know when people see these they know
it like there's nothing else to it it's
just answering this question so that was
where it started from like that using
the drawings as a way to get people and
it's like accidental learning yeah I
don't know I accidentally learned
something has a big set now from
learning oh one last question and this
is another one from Twitter it's from Oh
Vsauce three that's really uh who that I
don't know but everyone should go
subscribe you've been doing YouTube for
almost three years now you have a book
what else do you want to accomplish
where does ASAP science go from here
well we want to keep going we as we've
said we're really interested in trying
to get science and pop culture to mix so
we want to think about that so we've
started a second channel East I thought
where we actually talk more about pop
culture and social justice and other
things that were interesting because we
like things outside of sine um we
started vlogging our lives you can now
watch all of our lies yeah for us it's
just like bigger and better questions
like what else are people curious about
what are new ways that we can get people
to learn so maybe that steps outside of
the whiteboard and goes into something
else that's a little bit more in depth
for people yeah it's just constantly
brainstorming on like what
connects with someone how can we give
you guys an experience to make you
curious in that moment and thankfully
science is about evolution and
innovation so innately we have to keep
evolving and then perfect well I think
it's an innovating I if we could I'd
like to do something now and I think
we'd all would like this we've all been
thinking it is having said it's very
polite thank you which is since we have
the book here could we could you read a
part of it and then could you draw it
while he reads it we actually did my
course over there favorite is selfie
science oh no it'd be your sorry okay
okay we can do this okay you like my
version of a marathon so okay all right
yeah okay so Jake's inspired selfies
science and actually I should get my
ASAP science voice on um how do I got
with us okay it's got a burning question
asking in the comments or on Facebook
and Twitter
okay there it is all right selfie
science why do we hate photos of
ourselves how's it going you're ready
for a big night out and take one last
look in the mirror before you go Wow
you're looking great tonight
you're looking great Greg oh thing with
all the confidence in the world you
strut your stuff and make sure to take
tons of photos to the night selfies
galore but wait you hate how you look in
photos and feel completely uncoated
genic so how come you never really feel
that way looking in a mirror why is it
that so many people hate seeing photos
of themselves but usually have no
problems with their image in a mirror
well you did that okay that's a guy you
know I got some Sophie all right part
one all right look you're going there
are a few factors that play with this
phenomenon but the mere-exposure effect
may be that is okay okay so I can't
write well I get my writing at illegible
and mere exposure of fact is an
important part of this and so I want you
to write it cuz you do the rugged all
right we can saw the teacher I just it's
like I'm supposed to knock you should be
able to write right
I can read I just can't write okay I'll
write that okay also I used to narrate
the videos but then everyone said I
sounded like the honey badgers then I
stopped thanks cyberbullying
it's a go I thought it's okay I notice
him like on the audio book I read too so
you got it okay so there are a few
factors at play with this phenomenon but
the mere-exposure effect may be the
biggest simply put we all have a
tendency to prefer familiar things I
could never have written like that it's
okay all right
continuing on after repeated exposure to
anything you will psychologically prefer
it over a version that you have seen
less often as crazy as it may seem this
has been tested with words paintings
sounds pictures geometric figures and
even structures like the Eiffel Tower is
that it yeah okay
all right close enough or like Mona Lisa
for example which is the photo in here
we're all super familiar with that photo
and we tend to prefer it over like the
thousands of other photos in the Louvre
because we've seen it so often this
phenomenon has even been observed in
other species from monkeys to chickens
many organisms have been documented to
react fondly to repeated stimulus got
the chicken that's from the chicken in
the egg salad yeah like that's a really
big chicken and it just so happens that
the version of yourself that you see
most often is your mirror or reflected
image every time you scare in a mirror
or a window which I know you all do the
view is flipped from left to right if
your reflection in the mirror were
actually somebody you were looking at
his or her hair would swoop the opposite
way when you raised your right hand he
or she would raise their left hand and
even that annoying pimple you have would
be on the opposite side of their face
chickens got pimples okay but a
photograph is oh this is a big bite but
okay not actually a bad right
and let it apart passes like that em
alright but a photograph is not your
reflected image in fact your photo image
is the way everybody else sees you on a
daily basis your brain however isn't
familiar with this view of you and might
interpret it as off in studies of this
phenomenon participants prefer facial
photographs of their mirror image to the
photo image without knowing which was
which their friends however rated their
photo image as preferable so if your
acquaintances and loved ones suddenly
saw your mirrored so they would find it
slightly off its accounting grade those
my brain all right we're almost a rosy
add to this the fact that you can adjust
your position hair smiling from the
mirror and that photographs photographs
can capture angles that you can't see in
the reflection and you've got a good
case against your photo image but just
know that there's nothing to worry about
the photo version of you looks great to
everybody else so angling a vein of
selfies we thought we're all good we're
gonna take a selfie right now we're
going to use the hashtag it's up live
and if you're at home watching take a
selfie of yourself
watch me to us and we'll hear hey
everyone hey cheese and that one with
this side take over here right G okay
alright sweet okay cool well now we
actually wanted to introduce another
special guest yeah so another person is
here who we love and his near and dear
to our hearts she's a science
communicator and she has a YouTube
channel it's youtube.com slash
braincraft check it out it's super
crafty and artsy and yeah so her name is
Vanessa
okay so why don't you tell us something
interesting I would love to I'm so
excited about your book oh all right
well we'll let you go yeah science is
awesome I love lots of things about
science I'm sure all of you guys do as
well but something that I love is that
science gives us a different idea about
the things that we know best like
yourselves or our brains or even pizza
yes Pizza okay so this is a super
addictive food if you think about things
like the sugar in the tomato sauce the
carbohydrates in the crust there's
another little thing a chemical called
casein that's in the cheese when you eat
those all of those things together
activate your dopamine receptors which
are linked to addiction so it feeds into
your reward system I feel like kind of
Pizza evangelists okay Peter aside are
you guys probably remember science from
learning the periodic table in high
school learning all of those elements I
know that I had to do that we had to
like recite them to our science teacher
well since then I think that science has
gotten a lot cooler and so has the
periodic table so for the final time
tonight
here are Mitch and Greg with the
periodic table song
I mean really who hasn't wanted to learn
the periodic table song by heart right
you all know right uh-huh
there's hydrogen and helium and lithium
beryllium boron carbon everywhere
nitrogen all through the air
well oxygen so you can breathe and
fluorine for your pretty teeny on to
light up the side sodium for salty turns
magnesium aluminium silicon phosphorus
and sulfur chlorine and argon potassium
and calcium so yogurt strong sandy on
titanium may go beyond and agony this is
the periodic table the bogus table
react agressively this period we'll see
shall be like jungle to the right I
heard is the 26th and cobalt nickel
coins you get copper zinc and gallium
germanium and arsenic selenium and
bromine from on Krypton I'll slide up
your penny on the strontium then yttrium
zirconium niobium molybdenum technetium
ruthenium rhodium palladium silverware
then cadmium and indium tin cans
antimony and Tulare on the iodine if
they not in the Divya ma'am barium is 56
and this is where the table slang Harris
okay where let the Knights have just
begun lanthanum cerium praseodymium yo
demyans next your ever meet the ulna
sixty twos so Mary I'm your OB I'm gonna
Lenny of intervie I'm dysprosium holmium
- see ya - young tantor the bugs in them
Iran to become usnea and iridium but num
goal to make you rich all your old
mercury to tell you when it's really
cold valium is before your tummy Bologna
anyway don't fancy I'm alas a little
time Brady
this is the periodic table noble gases
table halogens and alkali react
agressively its period we'll see new
electronical right Antonia thorium
protactinium uranium neptunium plutonium
americium curium berkelium californium
einsteinium fermium and Olivia I'm mm
Lauren Zima nobody up there p.m.
civilian Berea Myskina back around Rafi
or any of governess
too young they were
you can get the book at Ames outside
about Sun everyone
so convention books on Thursday grunts
no